- Which of the following is
equivalent to all of this stuff
right over here?
1 over 88 or 1/88th, y to the 100 plus 1
minus this entire expression,
1/44th, y to the 100 minus one-half.
So let me just rewrite it,
this part right over here
this just be 1 over 88 y, let
me make sure it looks clear.
Y to the 100th power plus 1.
And then we're gonna subtract all of this,
so one way to think about it is
we could distribute this negative
sign, so it's going to be
negative 1 times all of this business.
So it's gonna be minus 1
over 44 y to the 100th.
And then a negative, remember
we're gonna distribute it,
so negative 1 times negative
one-half is going to be plus,
plus one-half.
Now let's see what we can
do to further simplify it.
So this is 1/88th y to the 100,
this is minus or you can say
negative 1/44th y to the
100th, and so we can add
these two terms together.
This is going to be, we could write this,
1 over 88 minus 1 over 44 y to the 100th.
And then you have plus 1 plus one-half,
so that's pretty straightforward.
So you have plus 1 plus one-half,
so it's gonna be plus three halves.
And now we just have to
figure out what this is,
so 1/88th minus 1/44th, well
the common denominator here
could be 88, that is the least
common multiple of 44 and 88,
88 is divisible by 44.
So if we multiply the
denominator by two, you get 88.
Multiply the numerator
by two, you get two.
2/88th is the same thing as 1/44th.
So this is 1/88 minus 2/88th,
well this is going to give us
this right over here is going to give us,
minus or negative 1/88th.
1/88th minus 2/88th is
going to be negative 1/88th
y to the 100, y to the
100 plus three-halves,
plus three-halves.
And that is negative 1/88th y to the 100th
plus three-halves, this
choice right over here.